straight ahead online grime daily
a mother working as a food delivery
driver fatally stabbed in the neck
the suspect now behind bars turned out
to be two 14 year old juveniles
a police officer now recovering from a
shot in the back how a routine shift
turned violent quickly they encountered
this individual and within minutes
within seconds
they were in a gunfight an nfl player is
facing felony charges
accused of attacking his own girlfriend
plus emotional statements from three
families
their loved ones beat to death with a
baseball bat by a former pro player
you're an evil person brandon go enjoy
your cage at the top ramen
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
two teenage boys are in jail in texas
charged with murdering a delivery driver
law and crimes angenette levy spoke with
police and has more on the victim
and the suspects yeah brian those two 14
year old boys are being held on capitol
murder charges in ryan muncie graham's
death
her family is grieving and preparing for
her funeral
last saturday night ryan munsey graham
was just doing her job
delivering food for uber eats to an
apartment complex in haltom city texas
near fort worth
when she was attacked the delivery was
never made
the food was found beside her on the
ground
so we believe that the two juvenile
suspects in this case
basically were just out trying to find
somebody to rob
and they ran into her sergeant eric
peters says detectives used surveillance
video to locate
suspects two 14 year old boys who lived
in an apartment complex nearby
prosecutors say the teens confessed and
wanted to steal graham's car
but couldn't find her keys so they
stabbed her in the neck
and took her phone the fact that they're
juveniles i mean just
i mean for you know a phone we're
talking about a phone
a phone that everybody should know
nowadays
you really can't do anything with unless
it's your phone
peters says graham's phone was found in
a dumpster at the apartment building
where the boys lived
graham had three children and a husband
cameron who told me she loved her
children
and helping people a gofundme page has
raised more than
70 thousand dollars for her family who
are reeling from the pain of such a
senseless crime
for them to be juveniles to do this
that's that's it's kind of
not the norm um so yeah it is it is kind
of shocking in that sense
now during the initial detention hearing
for both of those teens it was revealed
that they were both on probation for
evading arrest
one was actually also on probation for
breaking into a vehicle and had
marijuana in his system
the tarrant county district attorney's
office is not commenting right now on
whether or not those teens will be
charged as adults
brian thanks angenet joining us for
legal analysis is criminal defense
attorney
charlie rickers along with terry austin
charlie
murder in the attempt to steal a car or
a cell phone as it ended up being that's
capital murder in texas and if they're
tried as adults that's punishable by
life without parole or the death penalty
if you're the defense attorney here in
this case what's the goal here and how
do you get there
yeah you know it's it's critical
especially at this stage to try to keep
these uh
teenagers in juvenile court and you know
angenette indicated that these two might
have
uh criminal records which obviously cuts
against keeping them in juvenile court
however they're not close to turning 18.
i think it would be a different story
if these individuals were 16 or 17 years
old but
by the fact that they're four years
prior to turning 18
we all heard what the sergeant who
investigated this case said
about the silliness that they were doing
is to take a phone that is essentially
not
usable that really indicates that their
maturity level is not
really nearing the point of adulthood
and hopefully
a juvenile court will be able to
adequately punish and rehabilitate
each teenager so that they can stay in
juvenile court as opposed to
going into the adult system and being
shaped in their early teenage years
in a prison it seems like an argument
the defense will likely
put forward in front of a judge anjanet
the attorneys for the two teenagers are
already raising questions
about the evidence right yeah that's
right and the judge actually even raised
some of the some
the same questions that the defense
attorneys did they were questioning
the exact way that the police were
led to these two children they are
children they're 14 year old boys
so there were there was an eyewitness
there was surveillance video but they
were really pressing the prosecutor in
the hearing about
what led the police to them they're also
questioning the statement that the two
teens gave to law enforcement
and how voluntary that statement might
have been
something for the defense to think their
teeth and terry they're 14 could be
tried as adults or
as juveniles what do you think the state
will prosecute this case as
you know i definitely think at the end
of the day they're going to prosecute
them
as children because like charlie said
they are four years from
adulthood and they really did not seem
as though they
understood any of the issues that they
should have in a case like this
either way whether they try them as
adults or whether they try them as
children
we know they are not going to face the
death penalty because the supreme court
ruled in 2005
that if you are under the age of 18 you
cannot be sentenced to death it goes
against the uh constitution
of course and we'll keep eyes on this
case of course the sentencing is
different if they're tried as adults
then as juveniles we'll let you know how
that progresses thank you everyone
the woman once described as the most
hated woman in america
hopes her new business venture will
change how people see her
casey anthony was acquitted of murdering
her two-year-old daughter kaylee in
2011.
she's now launched a private
investigation firm people magazine
reports anthony has filed documents
listing herself as a registered agent of
case research and consulting services
llc
the business is registered to a home
owned by the lead investigator
hired by her defense team at trial
anthony's unable to obtain a florida
private investigator's license as a
convicted felon
reports say anthony maintains her
innocence and is looking to help others
facing serious legal charges in a 2017
interview with the associated press
anthony said i'm okay with myself i
sleep pretty good at night
the so-called q anon shaman pleads not
guilty to all charges related to the
storming of the capital
jacob chansley made headlines after
entering the capitol building
in horns and fur earlier this month
chansley's lawyers says his client
hasn't ian since monday
after being transferred from a jail in
arizona because the jail in d.c
isn't serving him the organic food he
needs albert watkins told the associated
press
that chansey would be willing to testify
at president trump's impeachment trial
because he felt duped by him chansey
will be back in court next month
still ahead on law and crime daily how
police use a youtube video to catch an
alleged prankster
plus a hero send-off as an officer
wounded in a shooting
is released from the hospital those
stories and more next
[Music]
a youtuber accused of faking a medical
emergency in new york city's times
square
to gain followers has also gained a
criminal record according to the nypd
police say the prankster known as
princey planned and filmed himself
apparently passing out in his car
officers smashed his windows and pulled
him out
to check his vitals princey whose real
name is zeeshan
cyroya was sent home but two days later
investigators found his video on youtube
and arrested him he's facing charges of
making a false report
disorderly conduct and obstructing
government business
a new york city police officer is
recovering after being shot in the back
the officer 31 year old danny vargas was
released from the hospital just two days
after the shooting vargas was working as
part of the nypd's gun violence
suppression unit
tuesday night in the bronx when police
say a suspect began running from them
everything i am about to say is
preliminary at this point
but in the course of seconds what we
know
is that our officer we believe fired one
round
we believe the perpetrator fired four
rounds
and during that exchange of gunfire our
officer was struck
what we believe is one time in the lower
back
below his bulletproof vest police
recovered this gun they say belongs to
the suspect
later identified as a johnny jones now
24 years of age
several arrests in new york city he has
a criminal record in jersey
when you look at miles the the record
what we sometimes talk about is probably
on the lower end in terms of criminal
record
jones was not struck and was arrested by
officers on the scene
he's facing charges of attempted murder
of a police officer as well as assault
and criminal possession of a weapon
our brave officer is 31 years old
he is a six and a half year veteran with
the nypd
myself chipotle homes
and the man visited with him and his
family a short time ago
i can tell you that he is in a lot of
pain and thankfully you know we expect
him to make a full recovery
the officer shook hands with his
brothers in blue as he left the hospital
in a wheelchair and was assisted into a
waiting van
back for analysis as criminal defense
attorney charlie rittgers as well as
co-host
terry austin charlie what was your
reaction when you heard this case
and with all that you know is this the
type of case that goes to trial or
something that needs to play out
yeah brian it's a horrific case and uh
this is the type of case that i would
immediately
attempt to angle to plead out now
anytime you have an
officer who's injured in the line of
duty you have an uphill battle
as a defense attorney and i hope that
this defendant
as most of the nation uh is wishing this
officer a fast and full recovery
because it's going to be even if it is a
plea i think it's going to be a
pretty steep sentence and as it should
be if you injure an officer with a with
a weapon
when he's trying to do his job
absolutely i know that uh
if this is in new york as i i know it is
he's facing at least 20 years to life
based on those charges
terry you've got to commend the officers
at least to some degree for the
restraint they had here witnesses say
after the shot they called out to jones
to put down the gun
and then arrested him without anyone
dying or there being a serious firefight
what are your thoughts on the arrest
well i'm not so sure i would commend
them they were doing their job
i am very happy that they showed
restraint here because we
know that in past history the outcome
has not been
exactly the same the officers really had
every single right to use deadly force
because
they were shot at and in fact injured so
they could have responded with deadly
force they did not
i do commend i guess you could use the
word
for using good judgment but they were
technically
doing their job doing their job
thankfully jones and this officer get to
both go home wishing of course this
officer of speedy recovery
as charlie had said earlier thanks for
the commentary both of you
coming up on law and crime daily why
rapper tory lanes is asking a judge to
speak publicly
plus an nfl player charged with domestic
assault
issues an apology is it genuine or an
admission of guilt
our experts take in just a few
rapper tory lanez is asking a court to
allow him to speak publicly about his
assault case against another rapper
tory lanez whose real name is daystar
peterson is accused of shooting fellow
rapper megan v stallion
in the foot last july a judge issued a
protective order against the bid singer
but his attorneys claim there's quote
evidence of gunshot residue implicating
others
and he's unable to disclose that
information megan v stallion
who is not subject to the terms of the
order has spoken out publicly about the
alleged shooting
tory lanez has pled not guilty to felony
assault with a firearm
if convicted he faces up to 22 years in
prison
nfl player is facing felony domestic
assault charges for allegedly attacking
his girlfriend
chad wheeler was released from his
position as offensive lineman for the
seattle seahawks
following his arrest king county
prosecutors say wheeler viciously
attacked the victim
choking her until she lost consciousness
the victim reportedly told authorities
that when she awoke wheeler said wow
you're alive
the altercation allegedly began after
the victim refused to bow to wheeler
he's out on four hundred thousand 000
bail and has been ordered not to have
any contact with the victim wheeler took
to twitter to apologize
events happened over the weekend that
transpired from a manic episode
i am deeply sorry for the pain and
suffering that i have caused
to aaliyah and her family it is time for
me to walk away from football
and get the help that i need to never
again pose a threat to another
back to break down the former offensive
lineman's legal troubles
are charlie rickers and terry austin
terry wheeler's girlfriend reporting
reportedly lost consciousness
and spat up blood the very next day with
the difference
of size between wheeler and the victim
many are asking
why isn't attempted murder on the table
i can't understand
why it's not on the table there's no
question in my mind
that he attempted to kill her he choked
her twice
she passed out and reportedly he said i
can't believe you're not dead
that shows intent as far as i'm
concerned
and there should absolutely be a charge
of attempted murder here i can see that
all right charlie
take this question as my informal
audition to be your co-counsel on the
next
richardson light case but you've got
wheeler reportedly being
having suffering from a bipolar disorder
and not medicaid at the time
could this fact maybe play into a lack
of intent defense or
an insanity defense what are your
thoughts
i think you're right brian in ohio at
least when you have
a an existing even if it is not
documented
and it sounds like this bipolar disorder
was probably documented for wheeler
he has voluntarily let the public know
that this was a manic episode which
relates back to his bipolar disorder
in ohio if you have an underlying
mental illness we call it a defect of
the brain in ohio
and that causes you to not understand
the wrongfulness of your actions
which is the key then you can be found
not guilty by
temporary insanity not guilty by reason
and insanity
even though he's saying 95 percent of
the time
if a lack of medication was the issue
and caused him to not understand the
wrongfulness of his actions
then he could be acquitted but still
receive significant punishment which is
usually treatment and be in a facility
all right we'll keep eyes on that
because of course there's a lot of
moving pieces there
will they go forward with that is he
remorseful he just wants to get that
treatment like he said in his tweet
we don't know but if we got an update
we'll let you all know thanks everyone
when we come back the emotional victim
impact statements from the family of a
man killed by a former professional
baseball player
we take you inside the courtroom for the
sentencing hearing after the break
[Music]
prosecutors in the george floyd case are
now asking the minnesota court of
appeals to intervene in the case
derek shovin is scheduled to stand trial
by himself in march
the other three officers are slated to
be tried later this summer
a judge has reportedly denied the
state's motion both to delay and rejoin
the trials
so prosecutors are asking for a chance
to argue in front of the state's
appellant court
prosecutors cite coven 19 concerns the
minnesota governor is reportedly
expected to request
4 million dollars to cover security
costs during the trial
including more than 600 state and local
enforcement
a former pro baseball player will spend
the rest of his life in prison
for a triple homicide brandon willie
martin was convicted of slugging to
death with a baseball bat
his father his uncle and a security
system installer
prosecutors say he killed them in a rage
after losing his
eight hundred thousand dollar contract
but his defense says he has
schizophrenia
and had a long history of mental illness
so the jury voted to recommend the
defendant not be put to death
a sentence members of the victims
families seem to agree with
i'd ask you to turn your head and look
at me in the eyes well sir
we don't want to have any of that just
go ahead and you need to direct it to me
you're directing it to him through me i
understand that
this man looked my dad in the eyes
before he killed him
and i'm not here to cause a scene other
than to speak my heart and my mind
and for my father who was murdered by
this man you took something so special
from me
you took something so special from this
world
you walked into that house not even
knowing him and you took his life when
he was trying to save your father
and your uncle you didn't give him a
chance you have no clue the man that you
took
if you would have just sat there maybe
talked to him for five minutes he could
have been the man that helped change
your life because that's who my dad was
for so many he was a councilman for so
many
he was a heart for so many people came
to him with their problems and he'd help
them
he walked people off of bridges who were
trying to kill themselves
he was the kind of man that saved people
and you just walked in there and took it
like it was nothing
if the death penalty had meant a painful
death
like you sentenced my father your own
father
and your uncle i'd probably want that
but how i see it
this man didn't deserve to be put to
sleep like an animal that i care about
he deserves everything he has coming to
him and have plenty of time to think
about that as you rot in prison
all of this could have and should have
been prevented
i'm very lucky that my dad was not dead
when i got to the house
on september 17th
i spent the next two days with him in
the hospital as he passed away
as he laid there in the hospital bed
with his head three times the size from
the swelling
i was able to hold his hand harry and
his family deserve the truth
he was hired to protect our family he
died protecting our family
he deserves the truth not some lies
trying to protect some racist mama's boy
that murdered him with a baseball bat
attorneys charlie rickers and terry
austin join us one last time to talk
brandon
brandon william martin and sentencing as
we heard there
charlie it's it's a tale of two stories
it's really
one family whose uh family member killed
two others
and then you have that installer the
security installer who is just
an innocent bicycle should never have
been there never have died when you look
at the sentence that was handed down
life in prison rather than death
do you see that as a win for the defense
here
i do you know being honest brian i have
limited knowledge about the facts of the
case but what i've read and what i've
seen on the show
a horrific horrific crime and
three people's lives were lost and i'm
thankful
uh that this young man is not being put
to death because i think the death
penalty
is one too expensive it's something that
can never
ever be taken away if we later uh
realize that
the decision that we've made is wrong
but yeah i do think that the defense
will consider this a win
and i think it's an appropriate outcome
in this case
now terry how much do you think the
families desires because it did seem
they agreed with this life in prison
their desires may have played into
martin not getting the death penalty in
the eyes of the judge
you know i think the judge did several
things here i think he
listened to the victim's impact
statements as far as the defendant's
family is concerned
but i think he also considered all of
the evidence that went into the case and
that evidence really did
show that there was serious mental
illness at some point
in the defendant's life and you know
finally i do think that he considered
the
jury's recommendation here because the
jury actually
recommended life without parole they
didn't recommend the death sentence here
so
i do think that the judge took a good
considered look at the case in general
and made the right decision at the end
of the day because as charlie said
you cannot take back the death penalty
yeah and of course like looking at the
case
you look back he was released too soon
um
from that mental health institution so
of course he might have played an effect
charlie terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you